[Music]
be [Music
]
rencontrez damien il est un employé fictif
chez optimi management une société de gestion de patrimoine
de new york
mais damien n'est pas à new york il travaille
avec nous
et il passe des appels du canada à
montréal
il contacte des agents immobiliers  réserver des visites
avec des courtiers
au nom d'un client étranger qui veut
acheter une propriété à montréal
son client tom bernard est aussi un
personnage fictif
joué par quelqu'un d'autre qui travaille
pour nous
tom a la soixantaine il visitera
des propriétés avec melissa ses 20 ans  -quelque chose d'
intérêt amoureux
melisa fait également partie de notre équipe et se
fait passer pour une étudiante de l'université mcgill
tom veut lui acheter un condo qui coûterait
au moins un million de dollars mais il y a
une
tournure encore plus surprenante dans notre
configuration
[Musique]
étranger plus  les prochains jours
tom fait le tour de la ville pour trouver des propriétés
avec son argent sale
visiter des maisons de rêve et des condos de luxe
parler affaires avec cinq courtiers choisis au hasard
comment vont-ils réagir
[Musique]
mardi 18 février tom et melissa
quittent radio canada accompagnés de notre
producteur
qui fera semblant  pour être l'assistant personnel de tom,
tout le monde porte un équipement de caméra cachée
qu'ils quittent pour participer à cette
expérience de trois jours
[Musique]
leur agent de new york leur a réservé des visites
dans des propriétés avec des étiquettes de prix que
la plupart des gens ne peuvent pas se permettre
ils visiteront cinq adresses de luxe
du centre-ville  tours de condos modernes
jusqu'au vieux montréal
et jusqu'au sommet de westmouth
me
certains appartements ont des vues à couper le souffle
tandis que d'autres présentent des intérieurs somptueux
le travail du courtier n'est pas seulement de
leur faire visiter les lieux,
ils ont également l'obligation légale de signaler
les tentatives de blanchiment d'argent
et autres activités suspectes  c'est
exactement ce que tom veut tester
oui monsieur tom est sur le point de dire très clairement
aux courtiers
comment il a fait grossir son argent d'accord
c'est l'
un des courtiers semble méfiant après
avoir entendu cette divulgation complète d'accord
les quatre autres courtiers n'ont aucune
réserve
c'est tout à fait le  en face de
beaucoup,
nous avons montré nos images à des experts,
donc
pour cet expert qui enseigne aux agents immobiliers
comment se conformer à la loi,
un cas comme celui-ci doit être signalé
kathleen
si l'affaire avait été conclue, les courtiers
auraient pu faire face à des
accusations criminelles
étrangères
une semaine après notre opération de piqûre  nous avons
appelé les courtiers
pour poser cette question
personnellement
[Musique]
quatre des cinq courtiers ont dit qu'ils
n'avaient été témoins
d'aucune tentative récente de blanchiment d'argent
nous leur avons ensuite dit la vérité sur
bernard
au moment de notre appel aucun des
courtiers n'avait
déposé  un rapport d'activité suspecte
tous ont affirmé avoir agi
conformément à leurs obligations légales
est
[Musique]
je dois faire preuve de diligence raisonnable je vais en fait
écrire l'offre mais je
n'ai jamais écrit d'offre
nous avons également montré nos images à osic le
l'organisme d'autorégulation
qui supervise les réponses des courtiers immobiliers
est
étranger
revenons à notre opération de piqûre nos
courtiers
ne semblent pas s'inquiéter de faire des affaires
impliquant de l'argent sale
notre personnage douteux veut autre chose
des agents immobiliers
il ne veut pas que son nom apparaisse
n'importe où dans la paperasse,
l'achat sera effectué par l'intermédiaire d'une
entreprise sous le nom de melisa
problème
[Musique]
euh [
Musique]
si les courtiers ne signalent pas
d'activité suspecte
à ce stade, il sera presque
impossible de le détecter plus tard
bfa
nous avons décidé de pousser notre expérience  un
peu plus loin
nous avons demandé aux courtiers une deuxième visite
[Musique]
tous ont accepté de se revoir tom
leur fait savoir qu'il
est prêt à procéder à une offre formelle
ok
étranger
ok c'est même le courtier qui
semblait prudent lors de la première visite
maintenant  a tous les documents pré-remplis
afin de procéder à la transaction
[Music]
n'est pas là même si c'est elle
qui est censée signer le
document d'achat formel
tous les courtiers vérifient l'identité de melisa
en utilisant des photocopies de ses pièces d'identité avec photo
[Music]
étonnamment, la loi permet aux courtiers de
conclure
de telles transactions immobilières douteuses
tant qu'ils déposent
un rapport d'activité suspecte par la suite,
certains de nos courtiers ont fait valoir qu'ils l'
auraient fait
dans ce cas, les taxes contre-fournissent,
mais il aurait
été
peu probable qu'un rapport après coup  ont aidé les forces de l'ordre à
attraper les blanchisseurs d'argent dans ce cas,
les courtiers n'ont pas de pièce d'identité avec photo pour tom
et une photocopie facilement falsifiable pour
melisa
c'est
[Musique]
l'agent inscripteur accompagne son courtier junior
jusqu'à la propriété la plus chère d'une valeur de
près de sept millions de dollars
il  prend l'initiative de conclure l'affaire
[Musique]
le courtier principal n'a jamais remis en question les motivations de tom
ni son identité, nous sommes entrés en contact et avons
demandé un
il prétend que son collègue ne lui a jamais parlé
des transactions de trafic de drogue de tom
la deuxième visite n'aurait jamais dû avoir
lieu
[Musique]
ces courtiers ont été les premiers à nous envoyer des documents par e-mail dans
l'espoir de conclure la transaction,
nous avons finalement reçu trois propositions de ce type
et réveillé
une archive